so this machine here is the 10 D
RadioShack why should I say RadioShack
really not asked we had Tandy America
had RadioShack so this is a Radio Shack
trs-80 or some very rude people say the
trash eighty where's the eighty come
from is that the processor and I'm not
sure it might be too tasty characters
across the screen actually probably not
sure with the age he comes from but but
yeah it's it was a good machine it was
an early machine as well the machine
itself was a valuable tool from 1977 I
think it's available to buy from
RadioShack stores over in the states
over here it was the Tandy shop was it
branded as a tungee machine over here
was it irate still a radio show I think
it was still a RadioShack machine TRS is
Tandy RadioShack so it's it was just the
same machine on both sides of the pond I
have to confess it and not really know
much about this machine over here I
remember Sinclair obviously when we had
Commodore machines and we had a core
machine was it not as big over here was
it big in the States it did okay over
here but yeah it's fair to say it wasn't
as big as the Acorn and Sinclair that
kind of stuff it was only sold by Tandy
so you had to go into one of their
stores to to go and buy one but
nevertheless I think they did sell
pretty well and lots of people had them
and we get donated them you know fairly
regularly and they were capable machine
I think probably they had a little bit
more of a lean towards business or home
business people that wanted to balance
their checkbook and that kind of stuff
but there were you know some some good
games written for them as well it does
feature in the ready player one of we're
doing a wallet videos about ready player
one what do we know about this machine
itself what's the process so what you
know is it running bass what's its
operating system all that sorts yeah so
when you turn the machine on just like
any other sort of 80s computer or late
70s computer it run basic there's the
way of program it this one we just
turned on first thing it does is ask you
the memory size so that was pretty
standard for the early basics they
didn't sort of automatically detect the
memory to use they asked you how much
however if you press Enter it would then
just go and use all available memory and
now we are ready to type code so
standard stuff don't want to disappoint
anybody
let's do ready play
20 you know what's coming next go to 10
absolutely bog-standard sort of basic in
the machine a lot of the time you would
have bought one of these not with them
on it so you would've bought just the
machine itself monitors were quite a lot
of money extra so a lot of people can't
afford that so you bought the machine
you would plug it into a TV we're lucky
enough to have had a monitor donated so
it goes complete with that just a mono
display though no colors but yeah I mean
it was a good machine but I think
probably slightly more leaning towards
the more serious side of computing at
that time so Bob by which we obviously
mean not very many games for it they're
not that many games for we thought that
is the literal good edition of looming
towards business is Medicaid
move along kids you you can read that
however you want I'm just saying it was
it was more of a serious machine but but
I mean in all seriousness there were
different versions of this so this is a
model one the most basic version of it
but you could then buy another one where
it had a monitor built into it so it's a
nice curvy front to it this was all in
one they had two disc drives there you
were pairing a lot more money for it but
then you had a business machine really
and lots of packages are out there that
helps you run your business and that
kind of stuff were processing CPM based
on Zed 80 you could run CPM on it among
those packages the machine does
featuring ready player well but I
haven't seen it yet so I don't know what
way yeah
I suspect that Ernest Cline who wrote
ready player one perhaps had one of
these himself because it shown some
fondness in the book yeah you can pretty
much go and see that yeah yeah
absolutely I think was planned adventure
games on it and things like that and he
he does talk about in the book having
the the shoebox full of games that he
brings out for it so so apparently there
was some games but maybe only written by
him I don't know let's go through the
power-up sequence so there's the
beginning of adventure just a purple
border with a number one in it so to
start any Atari game you press the reset
button 20 you know what's coming next go
to 10 so you toggle in the data into the
machine so you've got your address bus
there you can set the address and then
you've got your data